on April 16 Kurtz will head to the polls
and vote in a referendum if they vote
yes it will mean a new system of
government for Turkey leadership will be
under the executive authority of the
president and the role of Prime Minister
will disappear the president will be
able to appoint senior judges and will
also be able to dismiss Parliament now a
president rarefied air tawan and Turkey
says he's really doing nothing more than
having a system like in the United
States in reality that's not true it
would be as if the president ruled in
the United States but you didn't have a
Supreme Court and you didn't have a
Congress either to have the balance of
power now many political opponents are
very nervous because the president air
diwan's dictatorial tendencies
he's already fired a hundred thousand
people and put more than fifty thousand
others in jail
but he refuses to allow those opposed to
him to campaign what many people see now
is the formalization of an autocracy a
dictatorship rather than a real new
beginning for Turkey what are you
thoughts in the video what are your
thoughts in the referendum let us know
in your comments and also let us know
what other topics you want AI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds